there's a debate on Twitter Cristiano
Ronaldo versus Beyonce basically this
girl said that Beyonce had more Global
influence than Cristiano Ronaldo prove
us wrong
she basically you're the football fan
here she was basically like look I you
know I look at soccer players I don't
know any of them I live in America and
if you're trying to sell to me you got
to go with Beyonce that's the only
person I'm going to connect with and all
these people from all over the world
were like bro Cristiano Ronaldo's the
most sold Jersey of all time kids in you
know the Middle East Africa what's his
influence though did he change football
did he change anything what do you mean
change that well that's what influences
a bunch of people want to play everyone
wants to be him there there you go he's
influenced all these people to want to
be him I think Beyonce and JLo remember
in the 90s how much we liked that weave
this is like an embarrassing discussion
we're not talking about who's more
famous yes we're talking about who's
more influential I'm sorry I think the
original claim is that let's do this
because it's in the thing and it's more
fun okay who's more famous you just look
at the [ __ ] ID followers I think the
claim is popular but influential might
be more significant yeah popularity it's
without a doubt Cristiano Ronaldo yeah
it's not even a question I believe it I
I agree yeah but influence is really
interesting because there are people who
are incredibly famous but you might not
do anything because you don't want to be
them and influence has to have like an
aspirational quality and even influence
in terms of just the way things change
like Ronaldo there was always messy so
how much can you change the sport
whereas I really think in the 90s it was
like mainstream Beauty was like super
thin girls I think Beyonce and JLo
helped more than anybody pushing it
toward like now we like more
full-figured women we don't you don't
need to be that skinny you don't need to
be anorexic and all this [ __ ] look like
a woman yep I guess Beyonce how did
Cristiano and again I don't know the
effects on soccer but like is there
something specific that he does in
soccer that makes you want to play like
that like when Allen Iverson like okay
so so what came in with like a flash in
this like he made an entire like soccer
cleat like his own like the Mercurial
Vapor everyone saw it was like I want
that because Ronaldo wears those like it
was the fastest one he was the fastest
player on the field so everyone was like
yeah I want to be like flashy handsome
but
that's not input like what Steph Curry
did to like Steph Curry is way more
influential than LeBron it's not even a
question yeah in terms of like the game
of basketball staff has changed the way
that every player plays game basketball
Allen Iverson way more influential than
LeBron in terms of basketball changed
the way that people played basketball
LeBron more popular LeBron better Jordan
same thing like you could even argue
there was a there's a white basketball
player named Jason Williams yeah yeah
whose impact on basketball is that white
chocolate white chocolate was way more
than people that were way better than
him and the people who I you can even
say more skilled and all these other
things just because the way he played
the game was so different with Ronaldo I
don't know enough about soccer to say
but like I don't watch him and go damn
he's playing soccer so different when I
see a guy like the Brazilians you know
like a Neymar who's got all this crazy
footwork I would say though that Neymar
was inspired by Ronaldo okay like I
broke it down I don't know necessarily
either like how we impacted soccer
before but like for me at least growing
up was Ronaldo it was like oh yeah I
ever wanted to be him and he brought
like a flashiness to the game especially
when he was younger he was like 18 he
would just like stand in the corner and
just do like crazy moves and in my
opinion like watching Ronald or Neymar
come up like that he's a product of yeah
he's like kind of a branch from his tree
that like playing with super flash like
not us I mean he's like a team player
but still likes the attention on himself
and like just that component alone like
on such a team sport I think it's
probably unique but I don't know if he's
as influential as Steph Curry was to
basketball yeah because again I don't
know anything about soccer but it when I
watch him play it doesn't seem like he's
doing something so different than when
uh like like Maradona I see videos of
him like there's certain guys you just
see and you're like whoa this is just a
different type of maybe what Dove was
saying with a healthy lifestyle [ __ ]
influence to be on like he's literally
that viral video of they have the
Gatorade or the coke on the table when
he's doing the press conference and he
puts it down he said don't drink that
drink water and it's like maybe that so
it's bigger than little things like the
celebration like the way he would like
line up for like free kicks like
everyone would just do that [ __ ] I mean
even the celebration everyone does the
the silly [ __ ] like do it in the UFC
yeah like they do it everywhere and like
that's all from him it's hard to answer
this though because uh influence how
singers can't really copy one another
Like Rappers maybe can but no one can
sing like Beyonce and perform like
Beyonce they would like to um wasn't
Beyonce the first one to do the
unannounced album drop just all at once
in the middle of the night very true now
that's the way you guys yep oh that's
huge but you're influencing a singers
like it's a smaller numbers
every single person in the world outside
of the US
music around the world yeah beauty
standards I think again just to touch on
just those two are like pretty I think
Beyonce became like an archetype of a
person that you want to Aspire to be
like she became like a North star for
women like what would Beyonce do to the
left tell you even if she didn't follow
her own [ __ ] you're like what would
Beyonce do in this situation oh tell
that guy to leave Girls run the world
girls are powerful and I think that
influence to women was there to gay men
was there I mean she was like super
influential to uh dick lovers
all over the world but in terms of in
terms of like
he had influence is so interesting and
that's why I think like like okay to
your point about music like sometimes
the micro influencer like the person who
influences the famous people is arguably
the most influential because that blood
enters all these other people who then
give it to the masses you're more
Upstream the most furthest Upstream like
the producer like a new producer comes
out and all of a sudden all the songs
are done by them and then everybody's
copying this sound but it's all coming
from Metro Boomin or somebody I don't
know I'm just using somebody arbitrary
in this situation so yeah this might be
more of an example that's like a
gatekeeper than an influencer but
apparently uh Atlanta strip club DJs
basically they decide what gets played
in Atlanta and the strip clubs and that
decides what the hot hip hop interesting
that's the thing I've heard is like they
are the guys if you if you get your [ __ ]
that starts popping in the strip clubs
in Atlanta you're hot that's it
condition wide you're hot career ready
to go it's like in in um
art there's like four Galleries and if
you're in one of those galleries you're
legitimized as an artist and that's
[ __ ] influence yeah when you take
somebody from when you take something
with zero intrinsic value give it a
cosine and now it's worth ten thousand
twenty thousand hundred thousand million
that's influence the gallery has the
influence yeah okay Anna Wintour Kanye
there's a I was talking to this dude and
uh about some art stuff and I was like
what makes something like he called
himself a treasure hunter which is the
most fire [ __ ] term because it wasn't
just art it was ever he was just a guy
who could like hustle and
um he I was like what what gives
something uh well two different dudes
the art guy that was talking to me was
like what makes art value I don't even
understand this [ __ ] it's super [ __ ]
intimidating like what and he goes you
want to look for three things you want
to look for
um
somebody who
came in and is part of an artistic
movement so there's different there's
like post-modernism there's uh uh like
right now graffiti is is acknowledged as
like a form of art so like who is the
earliest graffiti person doing graffiti
on subway cars in New York if you had a
piece from them now that it's an
established type of art you want someone
early in a in a form of art that is now
recognized uh someone who's been
accepted by uh a gallery who's like been
in one of like the top four and then
also someone who has results from an
auction and like those are the three
things that establish value people are
willing to pay for it they're part of a
movement of Art and they're in one of
these like fancy galleries or museums
and I was like okay now I at least have
like a basis of how you [ __ ] vote on
or decide what art is worth yeah
because I don't know yeah you know what
I mean I could look at a picture and be
like wow that's absolutely beautiful but
I don't know what makes it 500 or 10 000
people say invest in art and you're like
what is a good investment what's not
yeah I'm just throwing money at Art yeah
but it kind of makes sense now it's like
oh yeah this was a this was a time
period where this type of art came out
and he was the the originator he started
it and uh then this other guy who's like
this treasure hunter dude and I was like
what makes something a treasure he goes
Rarity intrinsic value and then
mechanics something built brilliantly
something that is incredibly rare and
then suddenly has value outside of it of
just like the parts do you know what I
mean the Queen's watch okay is valuable
because people care about the queen and
that was hers so like watches the story
is important with the watch and the
mechanism but also how many yeah you
know and he was showing me this [ __ ]
10 million dollar car he used to drive
around in like London now it's a 75
million dollar car and I'm like why is
this worth that he goes there's only
four of them
there were two and then two got two more
got converted and now there's four but
that's in the world there's only four
and people who have tons of money want
to buy the things that nobody else can
have yes
and they're going to insert that value
he's also told me he's like I'm kind of
out of the treasure hunter business I'm
like why he goes you can't make any
money anymore
I go why not because everybody can
Google the prices
back in the day I could go buy a watch
off of somebody in [ __ ] Houston for
200 bucks right because they're just
selling it during the downtime then go
back to LA sell it for 10 000. now that
person looks up the price
uh yeah then you think about that like
the antique roadshow type shows don't
really exist because yeah I'm just gonna
google this that's it pawn shops like
everybody knows how much their [ __ ] is
worth by the time they go to the pawn
star show oh well that show specifically
yeah but you know what I mean like you
could just go okay I have this watch
what the Yeah that shows like scripted
they're like finding people of course of
course and it's great TV it's fun but
like nobody's they can't really rip off
the people that bad if there weren't
cameras there they're beating them
[ __ ] in the head yeah sorry
it's fake I give you fifty dollars
flipping it for 20 G's yeah let me bring
in my friend he's an appraiser and the
Appraiser's like this is [ __ ] like
throw it away what is wrong with you why
would you waste my time yeah yeah it's
crazy yeah but cool way to launder money
though
with art right like yeah every Art
Gallery I see that's just filled with
art in like Midtown Manhattan I'm like I
gotta be the laundry yeah of course I
mean that's the system you know and it's
you can be like they're like Charity
donations too like so you don't have to
pay taxes on it I mean it's just yeah
you just have to hope everything doesn't
fall apart because the first thing
that's worth nothing when everything
falls apart yeah is the thing that's
useless yeah yeah nft